le couvre-feu c'est une chose je suis
pas certain que ce soit la seule mesure
la plus efficace c'est d'abord une prise
de conscience collective à laquelle il
faut appeler la grande difficulté que
nous avons c'est les injonctions
contradictoires qui viennent de
différentes instances on peut pas dire
aujourd'hui que la situation sera
forcément très clair à l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens
je vous donne un seul exemple le on
attend un arrêté préfectoral en saône et
loire pour savoir si oui ou non ce week
end ont peu ou pas utilisés tel ou tel
gymnase en fonction de telle ou telle
public donc on voit bien que nous on
fera le boulot les élus locaux sont sur
le terrain ils ont toujours été son
contact direct avec la population mais
il faudrait aussi que l'état et à tous
les niveaux à commencer par le
gouvernement agissent un peu plus
promptement et en tout cas ne nous donne
pas des injonctions contradictoires
est-ce que ça c'est juste impossible à
faire appliquer